let's look at our playoff trees in the
nfc and they are uh more different i
think than in the afc especially because
you got the 49ers at one i've got the
49ers at seven yeah uh
and look i still think last year it was
so close i know it was so close for them
to be the five seed i just think it's
gonna be so hard for them to go back to
zero and zero and duplicate what they
did last year getting the one seed two
years in a row i just don't see it
happening chris no i it's very hard to
do it is the reason i did it because the
team i think really got better and they
have such an easy schedule to start the
year or at least a schedule where
they're going to be the better team on
the football field for the majority of
the first five games where i look at it
and just go i think that even if they're
not hitting on all cylinders they're
going to gain enough momentum and the
team's too talented to where i think
they have one of those years where they
are the number one seed and then i'm
picking them to have a letdown in the
playoffs play the seattle seahawks and
the seahawks have something to say
differently about that than the next
time around
so you have the seahawks beating the
cowboys in the wild card round and then
beating the 49ers i would assume in the
divisional round i do yes yeah and i got
seattle i'm a super bowl
i've i've got the buccaneers going to
the super bowl out of the nfc i'm doing
it what the hell nobody cares right no
nobody's going to hold us to this even
if you get it right like i you just got
lucky so if i get it right i'm going to
be doubting
buccaneers patriots
super bowl 55 i root for a good story
and there's no better story than that
this year brady versus belichick
in tampa first team ever hosting a super
bowl and who knows how many people
actually be there to see it happen what
a year this will be chief seahawks i
want to see mahomes and wilson the two
best quarterbacks in the game right now
show off that's my story that's why i
like it won't complain about that one at
all if it happened
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports